J Robert Oppenheimer might be the most
important physicist to have ever lived
he never won a Nobel Prize but he
changed the world more than most Nobel
Prize winners under his leadership the
best physicists of the 20th century
built the atomic bomb forever changing
the course of history if there is
another world war this civilization may
go under he has affected every war waged
and every piece settled since the end of
World War II
he also created a way for Humanity to
destroy itself now I am become death
destroyer of worlds
this video is about how to build an
atomic bomb the life of Oppenheimer and
why serious scientists were worried
about the explosion setting fire to the
atmosphere ending all life on Earth
part of this video is brought to you by
wren
When J Robert Oppenheimer was 21 he
placed an apple laced with toxic
chemicals on the desk of his physics
tutor the tutor Patrick blackett was an
experimentalist and he had hounded
Robert to do more of what he thought
Robert wasn't very good at experimental
work Oppenheimer had already been
spending his days in a corner of J.J
Thompson's basement laboratory
attempting to make thin films of
beryllium which were used to study
electrons but Oppenheimer was clumsy and
not good at this work
he was soon avoiding his duties in the
lab spending his time listening to
lectures and reading physics journals it
was 1925 and the 21 year old Oppenheimer
was becoming fascinated by the new field
of quantum mechanics
despite being surrounded by brilliant
physicists like Rutherford and Chadwick
Oppenheimer was deeply unhappy he wrote
I'm having a pretty bad time the lab
work is a terrible bore and I'm so bad
at it that it's impossible to feel that
I'm learning anything
friend walked in on him lying on the
floor of his room which he called a
miserable hole groaning and rolling from
side to side in emotional anguish
it was in this state that Robert
attempted to poison blackett
the specifics are lost to history there
are conflicting reports if Oppenheimer
used cyanide or something he found in
the lab which would have just made
blackup sick
this story sounds unbelievable but
Oppenheimer himself confirmed it luckily
blackett did not eat the apple but the
attempted poisoning became known to the
Cambridge University authorities
Robert's parents were visiting their son
from the U.S at the time and Julius
Oppenheimer successfully lobbied
Cambridge not to press criminal charges
due to his family's wealth Robert wasn't
even expelled from Cambridge on the
condition that he had periodic
counseling sessions with a psychiatrist
in London
[Music]
[Applause]
in the summer of 1926 Robert traveled to
the University of goodingin the chairman
of the department was Max Bourne who
just two years earlier had coined the
term quantum mechanics
Bourne was reportedly a thoughtful and
gentle teacher and had nurtured the work
of Werner Heisenberg Wolfgang Paoli
Enrico Fermi and Eugene wigner basically
the who's who of quantum mechanics the
class that Oppenheimer was in was also
extraordinary including luminaries like
Paul Dirac and John Von Neumann
where the academic culture at Cambridge
focused on experimental physics
goodingin was all about theoretical
physics and under Max Bourne's
mentorship Oppenheimer thrived his
mental health improved and he found a
community of people who were as obsessed
with physics as he was
on November 14 1926 Robert wrote to
Frank his younger brother you would like
Gooding gun I find to work hard thank
God and almost Pleasant
Robert was thriving and his talent was
being recognized Warren later wrote he
was a man of great talent and he was
conscious of his superiority in a way
which was embarrassing and led to
trouble
when Oppenheimer was 23 he graduated
with his PhD in physics he wrote his
thesis in German on the quantum theory
of continuous Spectra all in all he
published more than a dozen papers in
the two years he was at goodingen many
of them expanded upon the work of Werner
Heisenberg who was just three years
older than Oppenheimer the two
eventually met in 1927 the same year
Heisenberg published his groundbreaking
paper on the quantum uncertainty
principle by all accounts the pair got
along well
there was no way to know that just 15
years later they would be deadly Rivals
attempting to build the first nuclear
bomb Oppenheimer for the USA and
Heisenberg for Nazi Germany
time it was
stopped getting significant amounts of
energy out of radioactive atoms was
impossible ever since the discovery of
radioactivity by Henri becquerel Marie
and Pierre Curie in the late 1890s it
was known that radioactivity was a
passive process unstable atoms would
just Decay at random unpredictable times
and surely there was no way to control
that
in 1933 Ernest Rutherford oppenheimer's
old boss from Cambridge wrote that
anyone who expects a source of power
from the transformations of these atoms
is talking moonshine that same year
Albert Einstein said that there is not
the slightest indication that nuclear
energy will ever be obtainable it would
mean that the atom would have to be
shattered at will
so how would you break an atomic nucleus
well you could take a proton and
accelerate it through a large electric
field and then smash it into a nucleus
this is exactly what John cochroft and
Ernest Walton did in 1932 they
accelerated protons into lithium nuclei
breaking them apart the pair would later
win a Nobel Prize for this work
but a proton is positively charged so
it's repelled by all nuclei which are
also positively charged so to give them
a hope of overcoming this barrier
cockcroft and Walton had to use 250
000 volts to accelerate the protons even
then only about one in a billion protons
actually hit and split a lithium nucleus
so this would not be an effective way to
get energy
but there is another way
in 1932 the neutron was discovered this
subatomic particle that's about 0.1
percent heavier than a proton and it has
no electric charge so a neutron would
not be repelled from a nucleus and in
1933 Leo zillard was thinking about how
you could use neutrons to split nuclei
it suddenly occurred to me that if we
could find an element which is split by
neutrons and which would emit two
neutrons when it absorbed one Neutron
such an element if assembled
insufficiently large mass could sustain
a nuclear chain reaction
but the thing is nobody knew if there
was an element that had a kind of
nucleus that would do that
on the 29th of January 1939 Luis Alvarez
a promising young physicist was getting
a haircut while reading the San
Francisco Chronicle and suddenly he got
out of the chair halfway through the
haircut and ran to oppenheimer's office
Alvarez read an article about how two
German chemists ottohan and Fritz
Strassman had successfully split an atom
of uranium by bombarding it with
neutrons Oppenheimer was not impressed
that's impossible he reportedly told the
young Alvarez proceeding to
mathematically prove on his Blackboard
why fission could never be achieved
but the next day Alvarez had repeated
the experiment and invited Oppenheimer
to see it Alvarez later recalled that in
less than 15 minutes he not only agreed
that the reaction was authentic but also
speculated that in the process extra
neutrons would boil off that could be
used to split more uranium atoms and
thereby generate power or make bombs
when a single atom of uranium-235 splits
apart it loses a little bit of mass
which is released as energy following
Einstein's mass energy equivalence that
is a tiny amount of energy about 20
times less than the amount required to
raise a grain of sand the thickness of a
piece of paper
but atoms are also tiny in a one
kilogram lump of uranium there are about
a trillion trillion atoms so the energy
quickly adds up soon almost everyone was
convinced in August of 1939 Einstein who
just six years earlier believed that
nuclear bombs were impossible signed his
name to a letter addressed to President
Franklin Roosevelt the letter actually
written by zillard warned Roosevelt of
the possibility of nuclear weapons it
also pointed out that Germany had access
to uranium from the mines in
Czechoslovakia which was recently taken
over by the Nazis Roosevelt began an
informal uranium committee to discuss
this topic but then for two years
nothing happened
in 1941 Roosevelt upgraded the informal
uranium committee to the S1 committee
which would report directly to the White
House the explicit goal was to develop
an atomic bomb and in May 1942
Oppenheimer was hired onto the committee
to be the coordinator of Rapid rupture
so why was he selected
well after completing his PhD
Oppenheimer became a physics Professor
first at UC Berkeley and then at Caltech
the Brilliance he had shown under Max
born's tutelage didn't fade indeed it
blossomed into a remarkable but strange
physics career in the 15 years after
finishing his PhD Oppenheimer made
important contributions to everything
from Nuclear Physics to Quantum field
Theory and even astrophysics he had a
number of Nobel prize winning ideas one
of his students Willis lamb became a
Nobel Laureate but Oppenheimer himself
was nominated three times but never
actually won the Nobel Prize
when asked why he thought that
Oppenheimer never won the Nobel Prize
Murray Gelman said that he didn't have
sitzflash a German word that translates
to sitting flesh the ability to sit down
in a chair for a long time and do the
hard work he never wrote a long paper or
did a long calculation he didn't have
the patience for that
Wolfgang Pally also said his ideas are
very good but his calculations are
always wrong
timer was amazing with people he was a
natural and charismatic leader and this
combination his Charisma and his ability
to generate great ideas would serve him
well in the next phase of his life
[Music]
on the 18th of September 1942 General
Leslie Groves was put in charge of the
Manhattan Project I was responsible for
the development of the atomic bombs on
day one he ordered 1200 tons of uranium
ore the next day he ordered to buy the
Oak Ridge site where the ore would be
refined the next month in a surprising
move he chose Oppenheimer to be the
science director of the soon to be
established Los Alamos laboratory
Oppenheimer had just been selected to be
the Chief Architect of the atomic bomb
[Music]
the military establishment had concerns
Oppenheimer did not have a Nobel Prize
so would the scientists hired for the
project respect his opinion and follow
his leadership Oppenheimer also had no
prior administrative experience over a
large project like this furthermore he
was a theoretical physicist who
according to Isidore rabi was a very
impractical fellow he didn't know
anything about equipment and then there
was the problem of oppenheimer's
political stance he had links to the
Communist party including his wife
Catherine who was a member of that party
but Groves was impressed by Oppenheimer
he valued his overwhelming ambition he
also knew that oppenheimer's ability to
understand problems not just in physics
but chemistry engineering and Metallurgy
would be invaluable Groves thought that
Oppenheimer was a real genius saying
that why Oppenheimer knows about
everything he can talk to you about
anything you bring up well not exactly
he doesn't know anything about sports
the two men couldn't have been more
different Oppenheimer weighed half as
much as Groves despite both of them
being nearly six feet tall ideologically
Oppenheimer was a communist Groves a
staunch conservative
but Groves was convinced that
Oppenheimer would be the person that
would build the atomic bomb before the
Nazis and that was all that mattered
Isidore Robbie later commented that
hiring Oppenheimer for this role was a
real stroke of Genius on the part of
General Groves who was not generally
considered to be a genius
the Manhattan Project needed a location
somewhere isolated to keep the project
Secret Safe from enemy attack and while
no one wanted to admit it somewhere that
was sparsely populated just in case
there was an accident
Oppenheimer proposed Los Alamos New
Mexico he had fallen in love with the
harsh desert in the mountains of New
Mexico when he was in his 20s in 1929
Oppenheimer wrote to a friend my two
great loves are physics and New Mexico
it's a pity they can't be combined
but Oppenheimer had severely
underestimated the logistical challenge
ahead
[Music]
1943 Oppenheimer estimated that he'd
need about six scientists supported by a
handful of Engineers and technicians to
make a bomb
he was off by 2 two orders of magnitude
764 scientists would end up working for
the Manhattan Project 302 of which would
work at the Los Alamos site
over 600 000 people in total were
involved with the making of the atomic
bomb
by this point making the atom bomb
didn't seem impossible it seemed likely
on the 2nd of December 1942 a team of
physicists at the University of Chicago
led by Enrico Fermi created the world's
first artificial nuclear reactor pile
one it consisted of 45 tons of uranium
and uranium oxide and 330 tons of
graphite blocks horrifyingly enough it
was located under the stands of the
football field it generated about half a
watt of power
and if you can make a nuclear power
plant you can make a bomb the only real
difference between the two is how many
neutrons hit the next atom causing it to
split and release more neutrons if on
average that number is one there will be
a stable self-sustaining Chain Reaction
but it won't grow if it's less than one
the reaction will die down and if it's
more than one the reaction will grow
this is known as the multiplication
Factor K nuclear reactions are similar
to pandemics in this way
the simplest way to make a nuclear bomb
is to get enough fissile material close
together that it creates a runaway chain
reaction that amount is known as the
critical mass with uranium-235 you need
about 52 kilograms forming a sphere with
a diameter of 17 centimeters
if you use plutonium-239 the critical
mass is much smaller only around 10
kilograms which would create a sphere
only 10 centimeters wide
for the first few years the scientists
worked on a bomb with a gun type design
inside a gun type bomb you have two
slabs of uranium-235 both of which are
below the critical mass
then using a conventional explosive like
cordite you rapidly fire one towards the
other so the combined mass is higher
than the critical mass
when the uranium bullet is about 25
centimeters away the nuclear chain
reaction begins resulting in an atomic
explosion
despite the simple design it is not very
efficient only a small percentage of the
uranium undergoes fission so the total
yield of the bomb is much smaller you
also run into some unexpected problems
like how do you make sure the uranium
slides smoothly through the barrel well
you use oil to lubricate the barrel but
all the synthetic oils the scientists
tried would dry up in the end the only
oil they could find that would work was
the oil from sperm whales
only about 0.7 percent of naturally
occurring uranium is u-235 the fissile
fuel for nuclear bombs when u-235
absorbs a neutron it briefly becomes
u-236 and then it rips itself roughly in
half and releases on average 2.4
neutrons per fission but when you get
uranium out of the ground most of it is
u-238 which doesn't undergo fission so
to make a nuclear bomb the scientists
use gigantic Mass spectrometers to
separate out and concentrate the u-235
and the resulting substance was uranium
with a much higher concentration of
u-235 in other words it was enriched
there was another option though
in early 1941 a new element was
discovered or rather synthesized when a
neutron is absorbed by a nucleus of
uranium-238 it turns into uranium-239
u-239 is unstable so it decays into
neptunium which then becomes plutonium
there are three things that matter for
this story first is that plutonium-239
is a great fuel for a nuclear bomb it
has a critical mass of only about 10
kilograms second it is cheaper to make
than to separate uranium-235 and third
it reacts too quickly to be used in a
gun type device it would fizzle meaning
only a tiny fraction of the fuel would
undergo fission
but there is a way to make a bomb using
plutonium critical mass changes
depending on the density of the material
under normal pressure conditions six
kilograms of plutonium-239 won't explode
but if you compress it the atoms get
closer together and the chance of a
stray Neutron hitting the nucleus
increases so the higher the density the
lower the critical mass
so if you set off conventional
explosives around a ball of plutonium
you can get it compressed enough to
start a nuclear chain reaction and this
was the whole idea behind the implosion
bomb design
there are a couple ways to cheat
lowering the critical mass for one thing
you surround the sphere with a material
that reflects neutrons decreasing the
amount of nuclear fuel you need to start
a chain reaction you can also have a
neutron Source something that
kick-starts the chain reaction for the
first implosion bomb scientists created
a device called the urchin which was a
tiny pellet weighing just seven grams
and it would sit at the heart of the
bomb it was made of beryllium and
polonium separated by a layer of nickel
and gold the idea was that when the
explosives detonated the shock wave
would mix the beryllium and polonium
together and then the alpha particles
from polonium would cause the beryllium
to release a flood of neutrons which
would set off the nuclear chain reaction
at least that was the hope an atomic
bomb had never been made before
Oppenheimer and the rest of the
scientists at Los Alamos needed to act
quickly it was already 1945 and Truman
wanted to test the weapon before the
start of the Potsdam Conference that's
where Truman Churchill and Stalin would
come together to plan the post-war piece
the conference began on the 17th of July
the earliest date that everything could
be ready for the bomb was just one day
earlier so that is when the test was
scheduled it was codenamed Trinity
the night before Oppenheimer was nervous
there were so many things that could go
wrong the last test firing of the
explosives without the actual plutonium
core was a failure
to calm himself he recited a stanza from
the bhagavad-gita the sacred Hindu poem
he had actually translated the Gita from
the original Sanskrit himself
in battle in Forest at the precipice in
the mountains on the dark Great Sea
in the midst of javelins and arrows in
sleep in confusion in the depths of
Shame
The Good Deeds a man has done before
defend him
perhaps more terrifying than the idea of
the bomb not working was that it would
work too well
around 1942 Oppenheimer discussed with
Arthur Compton a terrible possibility
that a nuclear test could end the world
the worry was that the nuclear bomb
would create temperatures so hot that
Fusion would occur
a tiny fraction of the atmosphere just
one part in two million is hydrogen gas
but the worry was that at high enough
temperatures and pressures that hydrogen
could fuse together releasing energy
this energy would fuse more hydrogen it
could also break apart the hydrogen from
water vapor causing that to fuse as well
that would release even more energy
causing yet more Fusion until the
entirety of the Earth's atmosphere would
become a giant fusion bomb
recalling his conversations with
Oppenheimer in 1959 Compton said nor was
this all that Oppenheimer feared the
nitrogen in the air is also unstable
though in less degree might not it too
be set off by an atomic explosion in the
atmosphere
most of the scientists quickly realized
how unlikely this scenario was and they
continued on with the project so no one
took the idea too seriously but the
thought of starting a fusion reaction
with a fission weapon would become very
important after the war
the Trinity test was scheduled for 4 AM
but it was delayed due to a storm so at
5 29 and 21 seconds the gadget the
world's first nuclear bomb detonated
the high explosives squeezed the core of
plutonium inwards the shock wave mixed
the beryllium and polonium releasing a
flood of neutrons the urchin worked it
jump started the nuclear reaction and
now there was no way to stop it
just six kilograms of plutonium created
an explosion that was equivalent to
nearly 25
000 tons of TNT the New Mexico mountains
were illuminated brighter than in
daytime
the shock wave was felt from over 160
kilometers away
the mushroom cloud Rose to 12 kilometers
into the sky
it was so hot that the desert sand
melted into a glassy mineral now known
as trinitite
fortunately the blast did not set fire
to the atmosphere
on August 6 1945 the Boeing B-29 Flying
Fortress dropped Little Boy a Gun type
nuclear bomb with 64 kilograms of
enriched uranium
the nature of cellulose ignited pushing
the Slugs of uranium-235 together
tipping it over its critical mass the
blast from the explosion equivalent to
000 tons of TNT killed nearly 70 000
people
another 70 000 would die from Burns and
radiation poisoning in the following
months
three days later an implosion type bomb
like the gadget was dropped on Nagasaki
killing an estimated 80 000 more people
more than 95 percent of the 225 000
people killed in the bombings of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki were civilians
most were women and children
in 1965 recalling the moments after the
Trinity test Oppenheimer said that he
thought of another verse from the Gita
he knew the world would not be the same
two people
laughed
few people cried
most people were silent
I remembered the
line from the Hindu scripture the
bhagavad-gita
[Music]
Vishnu
is trying to persuade
the prince that
he should do his duty
and to impress him
takes on his multi-armed form
and says
now I am become death
the destroyer of worlds
I suppose we all thought that one way or
another
after the war Oppenheimer was a national
hero his portrait was on the cover of
Time Magazine and he became a household
name
in 1947 he became the director of The
Institute of advanced study at Princeton
he also became the chairman of the
general advisory committee where he
became an advisor on nuclear weapons
related issues he used his position to
argue for arms control
in August 1949 the Soviet Union tested
their first atomic weapon
and the U.S military quickly decided
that the best course of action was to
develop a more powerful bomb the
hydrogen bomb known as the super
Oppenheimer was against the development
of the super on ethical grounds and the
worry that it would start an arms race
but Truman's Administration pushed
through and three years later Ivy Mike
the first Hydrogen Bomb was tested in
the Marshall Islands it had a yield of
10.4 megatons of TNT that's 400 times
more powerful than the Trinity test
[Music]
a hydrogen bomb is actually three bombs
in one a conventional bomb a fission
bomb and a fusion bomb
the conventional explosives trigger a
fission reaction which increases the
temperature and pressure enough to fuse
deuterium and tritium together releasing
a huge amount of energy
in 1961 the Soviet Union tested the Tsar
Bomba the most powerful explosion ever
detonated it was another five times more
powerful than Ivy Mike around two
thousand times more powerful than
Trinity
this kind of arms race was exactly what
Oppenheimer had feared in part due to
his opposition to the hydrogen bomb and
due to his calls to avert a nuclear arms
race Oppenheimer was essentially put on
trial to revoke his security clearance
he had been surveilled while he was
working for the Manhattan Project but
that surveillance didn't stop after he
left many of the wiretaps were illegal
and warrantless Oppenheimer was
questioned about his ties to the
Communist party including his affair
with Gene tatlock a Communist Party
member while he was leading the Los
Alamos lab he was essentially accused of
treason and espionage
in December 1953 Oppenheimer had his
security clearance suspended his face
now grim and in black and white was once
again on the cover of time his security
hearings were international news
in 1964 German playwright heinr kipart
wrote a play about oppenheimer's life
Oppenheimer was sent a copy of this
script and he hated it so much that he
threatened to sue he especially despised
the final scene where the character of
Oppenheimer realizes the evil of his
work and I quote we have been doing the
work of the devil
to Oppenheimer it was always more
complicated than that
I think that it probably was assumed it
certainly was always assumed at Los
Alamos
that if the war
not over and not clearly
to be brought to a conclusion
by
diplomatic means this weapon would play
a part at the time
the alternative
the campaign of invasion
was certainly much more terrible for
everyone concerned
I think that
Hiroshima
was far more costly in life and
suffering inhumane
than it needed to have been
to have been an effective
argument for ending the war
this is easy to say after the fact in
1965 he was asked about the recent
proposal of talks with the Soviet Union
to Halt the proliferation of nuclear
weapons and his response was it should
have been done the day after Trinity
later that same year he was diagnosed
with throat cancer he was a lifelong
smoker and he died on the 18th of
February 1967 aged 62.
advances in science and technology have
given humans tremendous power to make
the world better or worse and nuclear
war isn't the only thing we have to
worry about human-caused climate change
poses a serious threat to ecosystems and
the most vulnerable people around the
world as I record this we are in the
midst of a heat wave and my folks up in
Canada are suffering in the smoke from
wildfires this is where this video
sponsor Ren comes in their mission is to
take action on climate change on their
website you can calculate your carbon
footprint which can help you identify
ways to reduce your impact and if you
like you can offset your carbon
footprint with a simple monthly
subscription while individual action is
important rent understands that this
alone is not enough which is why your
subscription funds not only carbon
removal and offsets but also lobbying to
enact climate policy and land
conservation projects I am particularly
fond of their new refrigerant
destruction project we actually made a
video about Thomas Midgley who invented
Freon which is a refrigerant that is
both destructive to the ozone layer and
a very potent greenhouse gas well this
project permanently destroys harmful
refrigerants like CFCs hcfcs and hfcs to
stop them from getting into the
atmosphere and this will reduce global
warming and prevent the further
destruction of the ozone layer it's a
win-win I personally offset my emissions
with Wren and for the first hundred
people to sign up using the link in the
description I will personally pay for
the first month of your subscription
this is an idea I came up with myself
because I think it's so important that
for those of us who can help that we
pool our resources together to have a
greater impact so I hope you take the
time to check out Wren I want to thank
them for sponsoring this part of the
video and I want to thank you for
watching